[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the decorated columnist for the la times
of course around the horn contributor
bill plaschke joining us from san
francisco how big a surprise were the
giants this year to you bill
well there was such a surprise dan that
i was on on the radio in may proclaiming
they would not finish the season with a
500 record
i thought they were i thought they were
a mirage i thought their mirage till the
end i thought the dodgers were going to
catch them it wasn't until the dodgers
stayed in the last sunday the last day
of the season when the giants when
suddenly the the dodgers were playing
the brewers and suddenly the crowd
breaks out in a giant suck chant and i
knew the giants had clinched the
division that's not until then did i
believe they could do it i don't know
how they're doing it half these players
haven't been in the playoffs before half
of them a year ago i never heard of half
these guys i mean it's it's it's amazing
what the giants have done what would
have been the fallout if the dodgers had
lost that game to the cardinals
oh baby well
i said they're giving they're going to
be the best team in baseball history so
uh i said it before the season so it had
been it had been steep it had been there
have been it'd be i mean it wouldn't
have been as bad as if they lost this
series of giants because it was a
one-game coin filled with the cardinals
and it wasn't really a fair
baseball soul whacked in i'm sure you
know you i'm sure you agree with me on
this right that baseball should have
seatings the dodgers shouldn't have
played a wild card game with 106 games
and the dodgers shouldn't be playing the
giants as early in the playoffs that
that's ridiculous so i think the fallout
wouldn't have been as bad as if but but
if they lose the giants
it's going to be bad it's going to be
real bad all the pressures on the
dodgers giants are playing with house
money dodgers have every bit of pressure
on them
but this is what i want to happen bill
everybody's up in arms because the
yankees were in a one-game playoff in
the dodgers in a one-game playoff that's
when you have change and i keep saying
if this was toronto and tampa nobody
would give a damn about it if it was the
padres against the giants in one game
playoff nobody would care about it it's
the dodgers and it's the yankees and
maybe we see change with the one game
playoff johnson you know i don't i don't
agree with that with the dodgers
standpoint even the yankees because it's
just one game they can always the gm's
and the executives can always say it was
just a coin flip game they lost one game
i don't think i mean it would have been
bad
but what's coming next the dodgers lose
if they lose from here on out
it's really busy no no no i'm talking
about major league baseball making a
change
and john smoltz was on earlier this week
and he said why don't you make the team
who has less wins they have to beat that
team twice whereas the team with more
victories only has to beat that that
team once i don't know if that's a
solution here but the one game playoff
while i like it i don't think it's fair
uh but i also think they should seed you
know give the dodgers credit for winning
106 games and you know they shouldn't be
playing the giants i agree with that the
dodgers are being penalized
for geography that's it's all about
geography and baseball and being a
sports dependent race sports
championship shouldn't be decided by
geography and that's what it is
how big a concern no kershaw for the
postseason
you know
not as much as you would think um they
have three three good starters i mean
they have you know they have you know
with sure scherzer and buehler and
aureus
and
tony gonzalez has been good as the
fourth guy not as much as you think
kershaw's been up and down
he's always uh one that's sore elbow
away from coming off the mound
i don't think that that's i think much
bigger concern is max muncie losing him
is huge that crater's a dodge who's
middle of their lineup
he bats behind trade turner has given
trade turner a lot of support this year
muncie's a much bigger issue than
kershaw
how much bigger do you think would show
hey otani be if he played
in los angeles as opposed to in anaheim
oh it's enormous i mean i've said this
before on the show mike trout could walk
into a coffee shop in l.a and nobody
would know who he was
shohei would be huge
and shohei might eventually end up
playing for the dodgers because he he's
not happy as you've i'm sure we've
talked about he's not happy down in
anaheim he wants him he wants change he
wants him to get some pitch he wants him
to get better he sees what's happened to
mike trout he doesn't want that to
happen to him um
shohei i mean shohei is on the verge of
he's all but asking for a trade the
angels better improve and improve quick
or he's gone and the doctors would snap
him up in a heartbeat he's bill plaschke
la times columnist around the horn
contributor joining us from san
francisco tonight at oracle park it'll
be game one the best of five by the way
national divisional series best of five
favor dodgers are the giants
i think i think it favors the dodgers
because they have again the three
starting but you got to beat
shares or aureus or bureau you got to be
all you got to be one of them and i
don't think the giants can do that i
just think the giants were a fun story a
nice dream season
i just don't think they're built for the
postseason and they're not built for the
starting pitching that the dodgers have
and i think the three a three game
series five game series it also
mitigates kershaw's loss so uh i think
it definitely favors the dodgers and i
think the dodgers are going to probably
win this in four i don't think he even
goes five
if i said you could pick the la team to
win a title this year you can pick the
lakers now you could pick the rams to
win the super bowl you can pick the
dodgers to win the world series
well we already had lakers and dodgers i
picked the rams because they tried they
tried so hard they built they spent five
billion dollars on a stadium they they
spent all these draft picks on matthew
stafford the rams have done everything
leslie has done everything for his fans
you know they've done everything for
their fan base they have tried to be
la's team
it would be that that would be the team
to win although i'd funny you mentioned
the chargers the chargers are becoming
la's team a little bit dan don't sleep
on the chargers of course you're not
you're always a justin herbert fan i
know that yeah
i've been on the chargers for 15 years
bill
you know i'm waiting on them they
shouldn't be waiting on me but i i i
think the chargers are
a really interesting team and uh but i
just i'm not i'm not sure they always
find the banana appeal there's always
injuries or there's always
disappointment
yeah they have to get over they have to
get over themselves oh i'll tell you
this
the charger pr staff they give us
parking right across the street from
sulphide the rams make this park far
away
no chargers
you know damn we cheer for ourselves i
know i know how it is to be in the media
like what do we have what's our uh you
know the press box spread that we're
going to have we've got the better we've
got the better break it's all about
the the lakers roster uh
you know we already had ariza who's
going to be out with uh isn't that
amazing they've already lost a guy for
three months
they're so old and creaky but you know
what they've all got their damn vaccines
that's all i care about right now they
all got vaccinated they're all sticking
together
i've been impressed so far with what
westbrook has shown he hasn't caused the
story yet so let's wait and see but i
think
just judging from the first week of
practice and media day and all that they
seem to be more connected they seem to
realize they're old they're creaky
nobody believes in them
they're kind of it's kind of bonded them
and i think maybe that'll that
collective wisdom
could make them a better team than i
thought they were going to be well what
i like with uh westbrook is that i think
he'll help lebron during the regular
season because westbrook will probably
take a majority of the ball more minutes
and maybe you you you almost have uh
load management for lebron without
actually calling it load management and
i and i think that that's important i
think anthony davis being in in good
shape anthony davis should be
giannis he should be done he should be
he should be their mvp he should be
their leader i've said this to him i
said this to everybody everybody says
it's out here the most important thing
in la sports perhaps in the last year is
how was his off season did anthony davis
make the commitment to get stronger and
stay healthier because it's on his
shoulders and he's got to realize that
this should be his team and it's not and
it should be and i don't think they can
win a championship if it's not because
he's only got it he's he's got the youth
and he's got the you know uh the
versatility you're right he should be
honest and he's not and it should bother
him i wish it would bother him more that
he's not giannis he should be better
than giannis because he shoots better
than giannis does and but giannis to me
and i've said this before the difference
between giannis and ben simmons is
giannis is not afraid to fail
that that hey if i shoot a free throw
and it doesn't look good or you know my
three-point shot he just never stops
whereas ben simmons
gets paralyzed and he doesn't want to be
embarrassed and anthony davis is
somewhere in between
yeah all you have to do i have to do it
with annie davis dan is look at watch
lebron's body language anthony davis
goes down
lebron rolls his eyes
shrugs his shoulders anthony davis is
always wincing he's always grabbing
something he's always hobbling he's
always limping
and it looks like he just is afraid to
be himself sometimes and that's a that's
a big that's a big secret question is
anything there's anything and maybe
westbrook can get into him and he said
that he said he wants westbrook to get
into him maybe westbrook maybe the
trouble westbrook on on these kind of
teams will actually be a blessing for
the lakers i i'm guessing that the
lakers used to be showtime now
you can call them slow time is that uh
you call bedtime early bedtime but you
know what i love it carmelo anthony says
it he says we're old guys lebron says
lebron reads everything i know they're
using this as it is but
i'll say this for all their connectivity
and all their collective wisdom and all
this stuff they've already got like i
said aries is already out they already
got one player out there and you barely
start exhibition games and one guy's
already injured so i i just don't know
how it's going to go well as long as you
have kyrie and what's going on that
nonsense with the nets it it certainly
helps the lakers
yeah i mean it's it's yeah because
that's the one
that's if the lakers are full strength
that's the only team that can beat them
isn't that only team that can win the
championships and besides the lakers is
the is the nets and i think they're
probably probably looking at that by the
way dan you notice this halo over my
head here
the l.a times book says you got i got if
i'm platinum elite i get booked into
heaven
oh is that what it is
i'm in heaven oh you are
it's it's a great it's a great update
i don't like that bill bill plaschke is
in heaven yeah
platinum status gets you a lot lot these
days that looks nice now that now that
i'm looking at that yes you have
there's thank you there's a
holistic illumination behind you very
very impressive you know you're in a
cult maybe in san francisco there billy
i gave him my card at the front desk and
he said all right you're on
the bigger floor is heaven
ellen times bears no expense in putting
us up i'm sure of that thank you bill
play nice in san francisco guys that's a
bill plaschke la times sports columnist
around the horn contributor